i saw um
that uh bun put together the uh houston
rodeo thing were you part of that yeah
man thank you thank you bum b for
putting that man that was some serious
though now the houston rodeo for me just
came on i know it's the biggest rodeo
right but me and my wife been watching
yellowstone have y'all seen that [ __ ]
yeah that [ __ ] is gay
man [ __ ] yeah kevin costner bro man
oh no
ranch man put me up in that bunk house
anyway so i was like my wife said she
want me to dress like rip you need to
dress like real
that's funny but i was like me and my
wife were like i was like yeah we should
go to the rodeo i want to go you know
like let's just go yeah let's just go
[ __ ] it's a crazy atmosphere and it's
explaining it to somebody who's not like
from texas or from houston or who's a
part of that then it's like it's trying
to you know it's like foreign but in
okay it's a rodeo livestock show rodeo
in houston where they actually do
livestock contests you know this cow won
this prize this whatever one is then
there's actual rodeo where there's
cowboys out there you know uh last on
some you know bulls or whatever they got
the whatever rodeo stuff they got where
you on the horse so yeah they bucking
you off all of that type they got a
little kid one where they got kids
riding on sheep trying to hang on you
know it's some texas [ __ ] for real it
definitely it definitely is and then
there's the uh the fair part of it with
all the food you know the the because
it's that it's not like the stadium
right yeah it's where the where the
texans play yes oh yeah
it's huge the parking lot's huge
so it's uh definitely it's like a couple
weeks long and they you know usually it
is mostly country artists
but they will have some tejano artists
uh you know selena was when she did the
rodeo that's like one of the most
historic concerts ever like just it's
like when she did the rodeo that's like
the original woodstock wow concert like
the type of history that goes with it um
and then you know cardi b they
traditionally don't have hip-hop dad
cardi b do it cardi b did it and i think
chance the rapper did it um and i think
those are the only rappers bum b came
out as a special guest for leon bridges
mm-hmm and i think maybe for beyonce
when beyonce was there but in terms of
rappers headline and it was only cardi b
and chance the rapper so for houston
hip-hop is she was who all did bun have
uh part of the show
he um had a it was like a medley of
artists you know he had lele shout out
to lele um she's on i think disney
nickelodeon she's also a rapper from
houston uh
uh then he had uh h-town somebody
rocking you know boots yeah latoya lucky
um myself slim thug zero
devin the dude uh ronnie spencer um
willie d came out
esg little kiki chameleon came out
toby in the wig way uh toby so fire yeah
yeah well i watched it on youtube
because i was there like a couple weeks
before in our youtube paul and and bun
and bo was telling me like yo term this
is the biggest [ __ ] i've ever done in my
life it's a big deal man he's like you
don't understand like 90 000 people and
this is our hood so he's explaining you
know i had never even heard of that [ __ ]
so he's explaining it to me so after
they did it i'm like yo let me go on
youtube and watch it it's like an hour
long the medley so i watched it and one
of my favorite things was not only did
he put on every single artist from his
hood like every artist ever he didn't
miss nobody he brought out like
everybody that he kept changing his fits
the fitz was so fly he got the cowboy
[ __ ] then like j prince come out with
the with the cowboy [ __ ] it was just so
like ill like he kept going in the back
come out with a different fur coat like
all this different fly [ __ ] that was
that's what i thought was flying like
put on your peoples
only person who could really probably
pull that off was bun yeah yeah man for
sure man and
like i was saying about the selena thing
when she performed she had this iconic
dress
that she wore it was like a purple dress
you know you know when jlo wore that
green dress to the grammys
the same way so that's how you know some
of the people that you know came to
perform it was just you know they i
don't think they grasped the magnitude
until they were there kind of yeah
because but definitely the people who
were into it were like man we should
bond for show man jake prince you know
you want to wear something that's going
to be iconic that people are going to
remember for years man that's you know
he was sometimes wore that at the rodeo
you know what record did you do i did uh
still tipping uh with slim thug and then
i did uh sitting sideways with big pokey